we had a new villain yo girl like i know
some dirt on you
don't mess with me a couple of newbies
and a bunch of nonsensical statements
no i won't stop katie i'll do whatever i
want this is your the bachelor season 25
episode 4 recap grab your glasses
it's time for roses and rosie
hi everybody it's me lauren zema
and i'm in a jewel tone i'm in a
high-waisted pant
i'm looking very 80s ladies
shabbily they notice the dress dress
impeccably
they notice the woman and speaking of
ladies i have some questions about how
these women are treating each other
and then carolina's the dumbest pro i've
ever met
yes everybody uh i'm actually not doing
a rose today i'm doing a shard and
hey to fit with my 80s vibe and because
i always think that chardonnay is the
drink of the ladies who lunch
and we need these ladies to sit down
have a snack and figure some
[ __ ] out you will feel uncomfortable
pretty soon what did you think of this
episode
let's get to it yes so i actually wrote
down
is this the season of meanness
if you're telling me the first time
things get hard you pack your bags yeah
i'm already like
bye and of course the queen bee of the
mean bees
is victoria brittany is like
straight up like serial killer weird
i will say i'm not that fired up about
the things that she says
only because they are so wild seriously
i just find them laughable
like this whole interaction with katie
the trash took
itself out can you stop seriously
she wants an apology because she
called another woman trash when i said
the trash took itself out
i just would love an apology because
you're not going to get her
victoria seems to truly believe that she
can express
herself however she wants she can say
whatever she wants
i can do whatever i want and i can
express myself with name calling when i
choose to
victoria i suppose that that is
literally true
but you will have to face the way people
respond to what you say
she doesn't want to do that
victoria seems to have some friends in
the house there
throughout this episode there were
people who agreed with her supported her
sided with her
okay then get out the house like
go home but we've got to take a break
from the insanity we've got to get to a
grounded conversation
so we pick up at the group date how are
you dealing with all this
it's the evening portion and matt and
the women are having some
lovely conversations including one he
has with a
gorgeous chelsea i don't know i think
people don't realize how
emotional hair can be yeah especially
like for black women
what i loved is that as chelsea was
talking to matt about kind of the
different struggles and the journey that
she'd been on to love her own hair
matt was really looking at her when he
told her
how beautiful she was you look amazing
thank you
do you know what i mean like you really
took it in and i believed that it wasn't
just lip service
or in that case eyeball service he does
more of the open eye kisses you guys
there is only one rose chelsea gets the
rose
chelsea do you accept this rose yeah
hello
tory i am sorry to interrupt but no way
matt i need to talk to you right now
okay this show is the gift that keeps on
giving
giving us new women
matt is told we are going to get new
contestants
there are some more incredible women
that are dying to meet you
and want a shot at falling in love with
you
and they're arriving right now it's a
little bachelor in paradise
it's bachelor in paradise so matt
let the journey continue were you open
to the new women
let me know in the comments below
although we know
that the original women were not i feel
disrespected
we're gonna get to that but our first
fresh face comes in
and quickly puts her face against mats
i want to make up for last time
yes britney comes in and goes in for the
kiss and matt's eyes are
open they are so open
they are more open than they have ever
been
i gotta move okay and shockingly
the original cast of women has a problem
with this
is she kissing you no this isn't fair
they have a problem with a lot of things
yeah i can express myself with name
calling when i choose to
we have talked at length about something
that i almost think deserves its own
segment this season
vicky's vocab the words victoria says
well now she's at the point of
making them up she calls brittany a
slower
floor [ __ ] horror
it's not even good you know it's not
even good like that's not like bring it
on worthy
she puts the itch in [ __ ] she puts the
[ __ ] and horrifying
you didn't bring it on victoria you
brought us down
floor [ __ ] horror
yeah okay catalina come here i would
love to meet you
but things continue to escalate now
we're on to
vicki's villainy yes she's not just
saying things
she's stealing them a new woman comes in
named catalina and she is apparently a
beauty queen
and of course victoria doesn't like that
so she takes the crown
right off her head so i'm victoria like
the queen
okay so i think i should have that crown
actually oh really
yeah i mean thank you
victoria like like she just grabbed it
she just stole it i was like is this a
crime
okay i think i should have that crown
actually is this thievery
i mean does this carry a mandatory
sentence in bachelor nation
thank you i don't know you know there
are no rules they say on the bachelor
but are there laws was it okay you be
the judge
let me know in the comments below and
you know i will say
these other women are not shutting queen
victoria and her ridiculous ruling
down are you quarantined and then just
stayed in your room as a backup
and now you're coming in it's like a
back up because some girls off
they are not overthrowing the monarchy
no no no the new women
are officially in and don't drink for
every
original lady who says she doesn't like
that
oh lord have mercy this is like too much
to handle
sucks i'm definitely thrown off i'm
pissed off right now
i don't like what's happening i'm
shocked she's not welcome
it's very shocking um to the system and
yeah i don't think a lot of us are okay
with it
and we're having a mental breakdown
right now it's very frustrating and very
annoying i hate everything about this
i don't feel good like i'm not happy i
am upset about the entire thing
i don't want them here go home
why are you being so mean to someone
you've just met
yes this is a competition show but
honestly as great as matt is
no man is worth that don't treat other
women this way
or people okay okay
and even morals ethics in general
pleasantries aside
there really are no rules on this show
so when the first group of women is
sitting here saying
it's not fair that the second group
comes in five new girls showed up
how is that fair it's a reality show you
guys
it's a reality show this isn't the
olympics there aren't any qualifying
times
is that what they have at the olympics
is that how they do it did i get that
right
i'm not sure but i'm gonna cheers to
myself it sounds good
what are regulations
it's the rose ceremony and matt does
keep
some of the new ladies michelle brian
britney catalina what did you think
about this
i wasn't surprised because i think there
were some gals in the original group who
he hadn't really connected with
try something new and you know how much
had any of us connected with them i
barely knew the names of the women who
left and i definitely don't know
the names of the women who've just
arrived but luckily
it's time for voguin with victoria
hopefully the newbies feel the pressure
and drop like flies yes
victoria is always serving us looks and
today her and her scarf are here to
inform us
that matt kept four of the five new
women
matt gave four out of five of the new
girls roses
so the new girls are definitely coming
in hot we're getting some new women
we're getting a new face sort of ben
higgins is here
and something else new matt is not
wearing a turtleneck oh we've all seen
it i mean
i love a turtleneck but matt and his
turtlenecks are his most committed
relationships
so i'm gonna fight for matt marie is
wearing a turtleneck and
i just wanted to take a minute to say
she looks stunning i love it a black
turtleneck and
hoops just a very classic look very 80s
ladies who lunch
when i think of 80s ladies who lunch i
always think of the movie working girl
with melanie griffith
and sigourney weaver which i love and
it's called work and girl
but it's not in the way that you think
the title would be
oh and speaking of we're gonna get into
those accusations later uh no it's just
about a woman who is working
in an office and in trying to work her
way up and you know who tries to take
her down
a mean lady good god tess don't you know
when to stop
no
we are still embracing our fall vibes
which i love
on the group date we're going to fall in
love
this is a beautiful fall day so matt
asked me to come here
set up the fall in love fest which is an
obstacle course
yeah you know i never know the rules
even though ben higgins is being quite
adamant about them
which is an obstacle course and it's a
foot race and it's a foot race
and it's a foot race to the finish i
didn't know what they were doing
we're rowing in pumpkins you're gonna
get
into a thousand pound pumpkins were
these
real what were they pumpkins we were
told
they weighed a thousand pounds thousand
pound pumpkins
how are they floating row across the
link
what is science i don't know but i
really related to maggie that's where
i'd be
oh and we're kind of getting a new mean
queen each episode
we wondered last week if sarah was the
villain she was not
is it villanna i'm feeling competitive
the og's need to win reporting directly
to
the queen victoria in this monarchy of
mean
monarch mean meaner key
yes anna is very anti britney she says
that
she kind of knows britney from the same
social circles in chicago
brittany i like recognize her we're both
from chicago and
she's like sketchy she's not here for
matt
so she hides britney's acorn i found
britney's
and then i hit it
oh all the drama of those squirrels
squirrel squirrels
get it i'm sorry i'll stop and
marry has won come on
though to me the real winner is us
because we got to see victoria in a
squirrel costume
on all fours digging around in a pile of
leaves
but now we're all going to be nocturnal
animals it's the nighttime portion of
the date
and even though we have new women even
though we're trying out
weird new dates let's get back to the
familiar mats in a turtleneck
hey can i talk to you yes villanna
is upset that britney is trying to take
her time and again she's kind of making
up these bachelor by-laws in her head
she says i've been here for three weeks
brittany doesn't deserve
time i do i've been here for three weeks
and i haven't had time like you can wait
your three weeks
and then talk to him anna i think
britney's been
quarantining alone in a hotel room for
three weeks
let her speak to a person
oh but anna wants to talk her herself
and she tells the other women
being from chicago where she is i had
heard rumors
she says that there is talk that
brittany
is having a transactional relationship
with men she may be having a
transactional
relationship with wealthy men oh and
that was a big
accusation but the only transaction that
britney is currently having
is between matt and his eyeballs
it's like kissing a turtleneck with
eyeballs i don't know
with these
look at you and matt can't decide will
he
choose a bride and now matt is
about to give out the rose and you know
real quick just for fun just because we
need it
don't drink for everything in this room
a lantern another lantern a table lamp a
standing lamp so many vases and a bird
cage full of flowers
why white i saw it all with my eyes
and brie gets the rose brie
will you accept this rose oh and then
britney gets confronted
brittany i really wanted to talk to you
yeah yes anna
says to brittany people were telling me
that you are an escort
i actually was getting messages from
people in chicago
that like you're an escort and all the
stuff she was like sorry you know that's
like a horrible thing to say
i think that's an awful thing to say
about someone and i want to apologize
but i was just like wondering if you
wanted to address that and also
you can't sit with us you can't stick
with us
it wasn't great i don't know how
britney's supposed to respond to this
the only thing she can say is that she's
not an escort
no i'm not an escort like it's just like
so ridiculous to even like
say that like to have that come out of
my mouth like and it becomes as she
said she said where she's always
defending herself but anna seems to
think it was an incredibly mature
productive conversation
she's like i'm glad we had this chat and
i'm glad
we have to that is not the ladies who
lunch conversation i'm looking for
what did you think of anna's accusations
against brittany let me know in the
comments below also by the way
if you want to be an escort you do you
truly
be happy be healthy be safe great
and oh this has been stressful
there's only one thing that can calm me
down a singular solution to my current
tension b-roll of fall foliage
how are you how are you doing good matt
and michelle are on a one-on-one and
matt's in a t-shirt so that's fun and
they're going on a scavenger hunt
we're going on an extreme scavenger hunt
i think is that what this was
maybe i don't remember the scavenger
hunts of my
days of yore but they went ziplining
and balloon popping i'll hold one of you
pop it
over they did a little q a how many
children do you hope to have
ready one two three three
and ultimately wound up in a hot air
balloon matt and michelle
it's time to take your love to new
heights oh my gosh
was this a scavenger hunt let me know in
the comments below
i put that aside though because i was
more concerned about matt's safety he's
very tall
and his head was near the hotness of the
balloon
you are a tall man in a hot air and i've
said it before and i'll say it again we
are in planes too much and we are
risking matt's head too much
we don't need a repeater of peta and i
also wrote down
i wondered i couldn't tell was the
balloon
going anywhere it seemed to be tethered
to the ground
and maybe i don't know my hot air
balloons but is that fun
you know are we moving are we up are we
down
are we here or there or anywhere why not
just stand out in a balcony
oh but they got their first kiss up
there
and this was big you guys sit back
buckle up in your balloon
matt's eyes we're closed
do we think his eyes being closed or
open when he kisses someone means
anything at this point i'm having a hard
time telling let me know in the comments
below
they are eating dinner together and he
really seems
into her they both kept saying it felt
like they'd known each other for a long
time
why don't you feel like i'm not even
wrong yeah
they have so much in common they're both
athletes they both work with kids
i love the fact that she's a teacher and
he's a former athlete constantly
thinking about like my students
they both even love the same quote
people don't necessarily always remember
what you say um but they for sure
definitely remember how you made them
feel maya angelou
you clearly know and matt said that time
flies with michelle it's like time with
you just flies by
or you know floats and hovers in a
stationary position
i mean he said he's seen all he needs to
see
i've seen all i need to see and we know
those eyes are open
but from easy and breezy to sleazy
and queasy back to the house
so before we start critiquing the
women's behavior let's applaud them on
something because there's one thing i
noticed and it's very 80s lady
this is so stupid but i love it they are
like
all wearing super cute gold hoops
maybe they're sharing them maybe this is
their season's version
of the salmon jacket that everybody wore
in hannah brown season and that would be
nice for them to be sharing
and caring for each other oh
but now we gotta talk about it all so
brittany is
explaining how upset she is over the
accusations from anna
an accusation apparently like two of the
girls like knew me before i came here
and i didn't even know that
and they wanted to spread a rumor about
me um
basically like saying i'm an escort
crazy and cheers to katie because she's
really become kind of the voice of
reason of the house in many ways the
petty
mean girl stuff needs to stop and now
they're all having a reason to get
their emotions out it's the group date
uh matt tells the women he's very into
physical activity being physically fit
and active is a major part of my
lifestyle which we
know and shockingly they're gonna have
to fight each other which we could have
predicted
and it's going to be in front of a live
audience you
all are going to be fighting
in front of a live audience
which was definitely determined
oh yes we have some new women but these
are some old tricks you know
um kids reactions would have been me she
was like
all right it's time for the battle
for the bachelor and you guys
you guys you guys
this is my nightmare
having to do a physical sporty activity
and like violently compete against
someone else i would have been like can
we do a musical
theater battle like like newsies
is newsies an 80s movie might be 90s
touch them up let's go
so they fight and they've got a lot to
work out this is no joke
it gets so intense and mean that matt
shuts it down
i had to call the fight it was getting
dangerous and that's not what we're
going for today
and we cut to the night time portion of
the date let's have a cocktail
let's all get along we want to feel like
things aren't too
crazy so again matt
is in a turtleneck
should we just do it do we have to do it
should we just get it over with don't
drink for every turtleneck
matt has worn this season crazy
like what more could you ask for inserts
i like to propose a toast to getting to
know each other better
i do love turtlenecks i do very 80s
thing to wear
so we're not fighting we're just going
to talk we're going to converse
we're going to verbally engage but first
we're
vibin with katie and i mean it's a party
i guess i'm giving everybody a segment i
don't know uh katie
though is going to go and speak to matt
about
some of the behavior that the women are
exhibiting
it would probably be a good time to
address some of the bullying that's kind
of been happening in the house so matt's
gonna go in right
i need to get to the bottom of it so you
better believe i'm gonna bring it up
he's going to address the women right
he's gonna say something
next week on the bachelor oh
we get the promo yes next week it looks
like we are going from the
battle for the bachelor to the war
of the women you put my character in
question
that's complete i feel you're deflecting
i don't give up
what is this scene where their power
walk dueling
against each other it's like we are
gonna throw down on this stroll
that was very newsies oh but what an
episode you guys
i think it ended with very few words uh
matt doing what looks like a tick tock
dance
in silence
what did you all think of this episode
what do you have
to say let me know in the comments below
and of course if you guys want to talk
to me more i am available on tick tock
instagram twitter
and for personal messages on cameo i
love you so much
thank you so much for watching roses and
rose tell your friends about the show if
they don't watch it yet
and now i've gotta say goodbye
to you goodbye to you
good morning i don't know any more words
to that song
bye